AND GROUPTHINK.
STAY WITH FOX.
SEAN HANNITY NEXT.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE BEGAN TONIGHT A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
WE BEGIN WITH MAJOR
BREAKING NEWS.
WE WERE RIGHT YET AGAIN.
LOOK AT THIS.
IN A LETTER TO THE FISA COURT,
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ADMITTED THAT AT LEAST TWO OF
THEIR APPLICATIONS AGAINST TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE
LACKED PROBABLE CAUSE AND THAT
THE SURVEILLANCE OF PAGE SHOULD
NOT HAVE CONTINUED.
A STUNNING ADMISSION OF GUILT
THAT THEY ADMITTED.
NOT ONLY THE RIGHTS WERE
TRAMPLED, BUT THAT MEANS ALL OF
THE SPYING, YEAH, THAT WAS
HAPPENING TOO.
WE FIRST WILL HAVE ALL THE
DETAILS COMING UP.
AT THIS HOUR, YEP, THE LIAR FROM
CALIFORNIA IS CONTINUING TO
HOIST HIMSELF ON "WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE."
HERE IT IS.
9:00 P.M. IN THE D.C. SWAMP,
6:00 P.M. OUT ON THE WEST COAST
AND THE SCHIFF SHAM SHOW IS
STILL GOING ON.
HOURS AND HOURS OF MINDLESS
ENDLESS REPETITION, BABBLING.
HERE'S WHAT WE LEARNED TODAY.
NOTHING.
WE'VE LEARNED ABSOLUTELY NOTHIN
ZERO NEW REVELATION.
NONE.
NO NEW ARGUMENT.
ZERO.
NO NEW DEVELOPMENTS WHATSOEVER.
IT'S THE EXACT SAME SCHUMER
SCHIFF SHAM SHOW OVER AND OVER.
NOW, HERE'S WHAT'S GETTING
INTERESTING.
IT'S ACTUALLY, IN A WEIRD WAY,
AND WE WILL DO ALL THE WATCHING
FOR YOU SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
SUFFER.
WHAT'S REMARKABLE ABOUT THIS IS
NOW THEY ARE RUNNING OUT OF
THINGS TO SAY.
SO, WHAT DO THEY DO?
AFTER REPEATING THEMSELVES
ENDLESSLY, BECAUSE THERE IS
NOTHING NEW TO ADD, WELL, THEN
THEY WENT BACK.
MEMBER THEY HAD HEARSAY
WITNESSES AND OPINION WITNESSES?
THEY ARE PULLING BACK SOME OF
THE OLD TESTIMONY FROM THE
OPINION WITNESSES LIKE THE
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR.
THAT GUY.
HE ONCE WROTE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED FOR TWEETING OUT THE
PHRASE "FAKE NEWS."
HE WAS BROUGHT BACK TODAY.
THEY REHASHED OLD STATEMENTS
FROM ALL OF THE HEARSAY
OPINIONS, NOT IN, NONRELEVANT
WITNESSES, ALL OF THE POLITICAL
DISAGREEMENTS.
THEY GOT SO DESPERATE TO FILL IN
THE TIME.
THEY EVEN WENT BACK AND READ FOR
THE MUELLER REPORT, THE ONE THAT
VINDICATED PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW, I'VE BEEN IN TALK RADIO FOR
31 YEARS.
I LOVE MY HOME, MY FOX HOME
YEAR, MY 24TH YEAR.
ALL THESE YEARS, I WAS A KID
LISTENING, GREW UP LISTENING TO
THE PIONEERS OF TALK RADIO,
BARRY GRAY, JEAN BURNS, JERRY
WILLIAMS, DAVE AND
WILLIAMS, DAVE,AND
WILLIAMS, DAVE, AD
WILLIAMS, DAVE, ALL THESE
AMAZING PEOPLE.
I WOULD LISTEN CONSTANTLY.
THEY WOULD SAY, TURN THE RADIO
OFF.
I WOULD SAY, OKAY.
I WILL GO BACK IN THE ROOM AND
TURN IT ON AGAIN.
WHEN A NEW HOST, FOR EXAMPLE,
YOU HEAR IT, BUT YOU ARE
COMPELLED TO LISTEN.
YOU WILL HEAR HOSTS, LIGHT, ALL
OF A SUDDEN, HERE'S THE NUMBER.
THEN, THREE SECONDS LATER,
HERE'S THE NUMBER.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING.
IT'S PAINFUL TO LISTEN TO.
WE'VE HEARD IT MANY TIMES.
MATTER OF FACT, IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED TO ONE GUY THAT WE
DON'T LIKE ON THE SHOW, ALEC
BALDWIN.
THIS TURNS OUT TO BE THE
GREATEST RADIO TAKE, NOT ON
PURPOSE.
HE WAS TRYING OUT, HE HAS TRIED
OUT TWICE FOR A RADIO SHOW.
HE WALKED OUT OF ONE SHOW.
THEN, HE WENT TO MY AFFILIATE IN
PHILADELPHIA, WP HD.
WE HAVE THE TAPE.
THIS IS ALL REAL.
WE ARE NOT MAKING THIS UP.
THE BEST RADIO IN THE HISTORY OF
RADIO.
LISTEN.
>> WHEN CAN WE TAKE SOME CALLS?
>> YET, WHENEVER YOU WANT.
>> DO WE HAVE CALLS NOW CUSTOMER
>> NO CAUSE YET.
>> WHAT NUMBER TO PEOPLE CALL TO
GET ON THE AIR?
DO REMEMBER?
>> DO I HAVE THE CALL NUMBER IN
FRONT OF ME?
OH, I'M SO SORRY.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
NO CALLS.
LET'S READ SOME MORE ABOUT
SCIENTOLOGY.
IS SEAN HANNITY A SCIENTOLOGIST?
DO WE HAVE ANY CALLS CUSTOMER >>
NONE.
SPIKE DOMINIC >> BOY, IS JUST
INCREDIBLE
>> Tucker: HE HAD TO CALL HIS
MOTHER, BECAUSE NO ONE CALLED.
IT'S PAINFUL, BUT IN A SICK WAY,
YOU DON'T STOP.
OH, MY GOSH, THIS PERSON IS
DESPERATE.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT SO BAD.
IT'S THAT GOOD.
I'VE GOT TO TIP MY HAT TO ALEC
BALDWIN.
HIS CAREER IN RADIO WAS NOT
SUCCESSFUL.
DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE RUN OUT OF
THINGS TO SAY.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
THEY'VE GOT ANOTHER WHOLE DAY.
AND NOW, MINDLESSLY, JUST
REPEATING THEMSELVES LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TODAY, WE WILL GO THROUGH
ARTICLE ONE, THE CONSTITUTIONAL
UNDERPINNINGS OF ABUSE OF POWER.
WE WILL SHOW THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ABUSED HIS
POWER.
ABUSE OF POWER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD THE
MOTIVE, THE OPPORTUNITY, AND THE
MEANS TO COMMIT THIS ABUSE OF
POWER.
>> ABUSE OF POWER.
ABUSE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ABUSE OF
POWER.
>> THE ABUSE OF POWER.
>> THE PRESIDENT ABUSED THE
POWER OF HIS OFFICE AND EXECUTE
EXECUTED.
>> POWER.
>> Tucker: THEY COULD SAY
ABUSE OF POWER ALL THEY WANT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE IT TRUE.
IT DOESN'T EVEN MAKE IT
IMPEACHABLE.
BUT REMEMBER, THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES, OH,
BRIBERY, HIGH CRIMES,
MISDEMEANOR, TREASON.
HE IS COMPROMISED IN THE CASE.
ADAM SCHIFF.
WELL, HE DOESN'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION.
HE IS ACTUALLY LOSING IT.
THIS PSYCHOTIC RAGE DELUSIONS, I
THINK HE BELIEVES HE IS LIKE
SUPER PATRIOT BUTTIGIEG.
HE IS PROTECTING THE COUNTRY
FROM AN EMINENT THREAT AND HE
WARNED US, A RUSSIAN INVASION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE UNITED STATES AIDS
UKRAINE SO THAT WE CAN FIGHT
RUSH OVER THERE AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO FIGHT RUSSIA HERE.
>> Sean: THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS IS ABOUT RUSSIA.
THIS WHOLE THING IS A RUSSIA
COLLUSION HOAX.
FORGET THE FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY FOUND ZERO EVIDENCE,
INCLUDING THE MUELLER.
IT'S A PATHETICALLY EMBARRASSING
TESTIMONY.
SHE WAS CLINTON'S ATTORNEY AND
WORK FOR HIM.
FORGET SCHIFF, THE CONGENITAL
LIAR.
FORGET ALL LOGIC AND REASON.
TAKE ON SPECTACULAR HYPOCRISY BY
IGNORING QUID PRO QUO JO ANN
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
FORGET THAT THE TWO SHAM
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA OR A
QUIT OR APRIL OR A QUOTE.
ACCORDING TO THE LUNATICS, THEY
ARE ALL SAYING IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN.
>> THE RUSSIANS.
>> THE PRESIDENT WASN'T PUSHING
TALKING POINTS.
>> RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
>> RUSSIANS.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> HE BELIEVES IT IS RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES AND ALL OF HIS
ADVISORS TO CONFRONT RUSSIAN
AGGRESSION.
>> RUSSIAN'S CONFIDENCE SADLY IS
GROWING.
>> Sean: GREAT, HE WON
EVERYONE.
HE WARNED EVERYONE IN 2015.
NOBODY LISTENED TO DEVIN NUNES.
READ THEIR INVESTIGATIVE REPORT.
BUT, NOW, BACK TO RUSSIA.
ARE YOU SHOCKED?
THE DEMOCRATS APPOINTED THEIR
TOP RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY THEORIST,
THAT GUY.
ADAM SCHIFF, THE CONGENITAL
LIAR.
I CAN'T KEEP A STRAIGHT FACE.
THE SAME NASTY DEGENERATE, LYING
TO
THROUGH HIS BEADY LITTLE EYES
EVER SINCE HE SLIVERED INTO THE
SWAMP.
HE IS THE BIGGEST CON MAN THERE.
FOR THREE YEARS, HE HAD
TOP-SECRET MORE THAN
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
THE SAME LUNATIC LIED ABOUT FISA
ABUSE.
OH, I WISH WE COULD TALK TO HIM.
YEAH, THEY DID.
HE LIED ABOUT TRUMP-ZELINSKY.
MADE IT UP.
HE LIED ABOUT SO-CALLED
"EVIDENCE."
THE SAME GUY, THE ONLY ONE IN
THE COUNTRY, AND THIS IS LIKE
DIVINE JUSTICE.
THIS IS THE BOOMERANG OF ALL
BOOMERANGS.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT WAS CAUGHT
ON TAPE TALKING TO A RUSSIAN, I
THINK IT WAS A RUSSIAN OFFICIAL,
CAUGHT COLLUDING WITH A RUSSIAN
TO GET DIRT ON TRUMP TO EFFECT
THE ELECTION.
>> SHE BROUGHT HIM ONE HOUR
RUSSIAN GIRL, ALSO KNOWN AS A
PERSON WITH A STRANGE
REPUTATION.
>> HOW DO YOU SPELL HER NAME?
>> OLGA.
THERE WERE PICTURES OF NAKED
TRUMP.
>> SO, PUTIN WAS MADE AWARE OF
THE ABILITY
THE AVALITY
THE AVAILTY
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
COMPROMISING MATERIAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL BE BACK IN TOUCH TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS TO OBTAIN THESE
MATERIALS FOR OUR COMMITTEE AND
THE FBI.
I APPRECIATE YOUR REACHING OUT
TO US.
>> Sean: COMPROMISING
MATERIALS.
WHAT'S THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE?
DOES VLADIMIR KNOW?
COMPROMISING MATERIAL.
THAT'S ALMOST AS GOOD AS THE
BALDWIN TAPE.
TOSS UP, RIGHT?
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THE CONGENITAL
LIAR, COMPROMISED CORRUPT
ADAM SCHIFF IS LIKE THE PERFECT
MASCOT FOR JUST HOW UGLY,
RADICAL, DISHONEST THIS
"DO-NOTHING" DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
GOING.
YOU ARE THE FINAL JUROR.
OH, THANK GOODNESS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GET TO WEIGH
IN ON THIS.
YOU GET TO SHOCK THE WORLD
AGAIN.
I HOPE YOU DO.
HIS ELABORATE PUBLICITY STUNT IN
THE SENATE IS A DISASTER.
HOW DO WE KNOW?
FULLY, TO ALL OF YOU READING
THIS EVERY DAY, YOU MADE US
NUMBER ONE ON CABLE NEWS BY FAR
AGAIN LAST NIGHT.
THANK YOU.
WE CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT YOU.
THE TV RATINGS ARE HORRIFIC.
ABC, CBS, NBC.
ABC AND CBS, 1.2 MILLION TOTAL
VIEWERS.
THAT IS AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER
WITH LESS THAN 300,000.
BUT THEY ARE STICKING WITH THE
REGULAR SCHEDULED PROGRAM DURING
PRIME TIME.
OF COURSE, THEY DON'T WANT TO
LOSE ANY MORE MONEY.
EARLIER, "CBS NEWS," THEY CUT
THEIR IMPEACHMENT COVERAGE SHORT
TO RUN THE SUB
TO RUN THE SOAP OPERAS.
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TURNING OUT
LOUDLY.
THEY AREN'T EVEN WATCHING RACHEL
MADDOW'S AREA 51 CONSPIRACY
CHANNEL.
YOU WOULD THINK, OH, MY GOSH,
IT'S IMPEACHMENT.
MOST PEOPLE KNOW HOW THIS ENDS.
THAT'S WHY.
LAWMAKERS ARE WITNESSING THE
SCHUMER-SCHIFF SHAM SHOW.
LAWMAKERS ARE STRUGGLING TO STAY
AWAKE.
THIS IS WARREN, CAUGHT PLAYING A
GAME ON A PIECE OF PAPER.
AREA 51 CONSPIRACY THEORIST,
RACHEL MADDOW AND HER PANEL OF
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS, THEY ARE
ANGRY.
THEY ARE PLEADING NOW, BIG AND
THE DEMOCRATS, THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE SENATE, PLEASE PAY
ATTENTION.
FAKE IT.
FAKE ENTHUSIASM FOR THE SAKE OF
THE COUNTRY, FAKE IT.
SHE'S BEEN LYING TO HER VIEWERS
FOR THREE YEARS JUST LIKE THE
CONGENITAL LIAR.
FIRST, THERE WAS RUSSIA
COLLUSION, THE HOPES.
NOW, SHE'S FILLING HER VIEWER'S
HEADS WITH THESE FAR-FETCHED
FANTASIES ABOUT TRUMP IN
UKRAINE.
MORE LIES, MORE PROPAGANDA, MORE
FALSE HOPE, AND OUR VIEWERS ARE
ABOUT TO BE LET DOWN
SPECTACULARLY ALL OVER AGAIN.
THEY ARE OBSESSED.
BY THE WAY, THERE ARE SOME GUYS
ON FAKE NEWS CNN.
HUMPTY DUMPTY AND HIS, I DON'T
KNOW, HUMPTY DUMPTY WANT TO BE,
SOME GUY NAMED OLIVER.
WE HAVE BEEN RIGHT EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
THEY SHOULD REPORT THAT.
I COULD CUT THROUGH ALL OF THE
AND TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
THIS IS HURTING THE COUNTRY.
FUNNY, BUT SERIOUS.
WE KNOW HOW THIS ENDS.
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT WILL BE
ACQUITTED.
THEY ARE HELPING HIM.
AT THIS HOUR, 45 REPUBLICANS ARE
READY TO DISMISS ALL THESE
STUPID CHARGES BY DOING SOME
PRETTY BASIC MATH.
THAT MEANS THERE ARE NOT
ANYWHERE NEAR THE 67 VOTES THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO CONVICT.
JUST FIVE MORE VOTES, THE
CHARADE WILL IMMEDIATELY COME TO
AN END.
NOW, THE DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE
MANAGED TO --
THAT WOULD BE SENATOR LISA
MAKOWSKI.
OPENING UP OIL HELPS HER STATE.
SHE'S ANGRY, RIGHTFULLY SO.
THE HOUSE IMPEACHMENT MANAGER
HAS ACCUSED THE SENATE OF A
COVER-UP.
YOU HAVE SENATORS.
THERE ARE A FEW WEAK REPUBLICAN
SENATORS THAT ARE PROBABLY STILL
WAVERING.
YOU NEED TO LET YOUR SENATOR
KNOW HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT THEIR
DECISION THERE, THAT THEY SHOULD
NOT BE VALIDATING WHAT HAS BEEN
A CORRUPT UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS THAT THEY ARE PUTTING
THIS COUNTRY THROUGH AN ORDEAL.
IT IS HURTING THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS A FARCE, IT'S ALL
POLITICS.
THEY HAVE HATED DONALD TRUMP AND
THAT'S ALL THEY'VE DONE EVERY
SECOND, MINUTE, HOUR OF EVERY
24-HOUR DAY FOR THREE LONG
YEARS.
NO CRIMES, NO MISDEMEANORS, NO
BRIBERY, NO TREASON.
THE HOUSTON AND EVEN BOTHER TO
SUBPOENA THE WITNESSES THAT THEY
ARE SAYING THE SENATE MUST
SUBPOENA.
YOU GO TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
AND YOU SAY, EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, WHICH CAN BE TRACED
BACK TO GEORGE WASHINGTON, YOU
WOULD BE DESTROYING THE POWER OF
THE PRESIDENCY AND SPINNING ON
THE CONSTITUTION.
ACT SERIOUS.
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT THE SCHUMER
SCHUMER-SCHIFF SHAM SHOW IS
NOTHING BUT REVENGE.
THEY HAVE BEEN DREAMING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT SINCE 2016.
WASHINGTON
19SHINGTON
19 MINGTON
19 MINUTON
19 MINUTES, THIS INSANE
POLITICAL STUNT THEY HAVE PUT
THIS COUNTRY THROUGH FOR THREE
YEARS IS LONG ENOUGH.
HOW ABOUT WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE
OF THIS COUNTRY.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PUBLIC
SERVANTS.
THIS HAS GOT TO END.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU GET TO
SHOCK THE WORLD.
IN 285 DAYS, YOU WILL BE THE
ULTIMATE JURY.
I HOPE YOU SHOCK THE WORLD AGAIN
AND YOU DON'T REWARD WHAT
THEY'VE DONE TO THIS COUNTRY FOR
THREE YEARS.
AS WE SPEAK, WE ARE WATCHING THE
TALE OF TWO COAMERICANS HERE.
YOU'VE GOT THE PRESIDENT,
RACKING UP IN THE LAST WEEK AND
A HALF, ONE MAJOR A COMPLIMENT
AFTER ANOTHER.
LOOK AT THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
RECORD BREAKING NEW TRADE DEALS,
$220 BILLION WITH CHINA.
FARMERS, MANUFACTURERS,
AUTOWORKERS, ENERGY SECTOR,
SERVICE SECTOR, JAPAN, EUROPE,
CANADA.
A COUPLE GREAT YEARS
"RECORD LAUREL
ON EMPLOYMENT EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC.
WHAT HAVE THE REPUBLICANS
WHAT HAVE THE DEPUBLICANS
WHAT HAVE THE DONUBLICANS
WHAT HAVE THE DON MLICANS
WHAT HAVE THE DON MIKCANS
WHAT HAVE THE DON MIKEANS
WHAT HAVE THE DON MIKE TS